first of all how did you decide to make
it a prequel you know why wasn't it a
sequel what why did that why did a
prequel appeal on this I think we got
together about five years ago just
thinking about the characters and
thinking maybe there's something there
we love to those characters and we
thought if we did anything we wanted to
do something that got involved a little
bit more in the relationship of Mike and
Sully right and in talking about that
that's when we decided well the best way
to learn more about the relationship
would be to go back and see the moment
when they actually met that was kind of
the genesis of the idea we we knew that
that will that then led to the college
which we thought would be really fun but
it was really the Mike story of it that
got us most excited a lot of people
think that sequels or prequels are
easier because you have this world
already established but I think it is
it's a it's also a limitation so you get
some things for free I guess what we got
was kind of the overall look of the
world we you know and the the kind of
overall overarching production design
the palette I think is but but even that
we changed even even ours is slightly
brighter I think and a little more
vibrant than than the first film you
know we see it as all of our movies it's
not a competitive thing or anything like
that
and Pete docter who was the original
director was very involved in this movie
the entire time he was very trusting of
us it could have been difficult I
imagine it must have been difficult to
have your world you know handled by
other people it was really important to
put together a strong team and and but
day to day I mean we're in reviews
together a lot we usually kick off the
day together and kind of look at what
the day is and then often I have to go
to other meetings and and he's in
reviews with the crew and I'll try and
get in there when I can and then at the
end of the day we meet again just to
fill each other in talk about what what
worked what didn't gossip gossip
animation is already tough you have to
be really broad for it to read so I
think that John
had to be even broader I mean it was
really on their shoulders a lot to just
have even more energy the the sessions I
think as a result were exhausting
because we didn't do anything to their
voices it helps that they're monsters to
know the young monster sounds like
they're still gruff maybe their voices
sound younger as they get older no you
know as much as we could we tried to
record them together which is rare and
animation it doesn't always work but
they have great chemistry they get along
with each other they like each other
they make each other laugh and my job
again is to give them playable direction
and then get out of the way and see what
happens
in order to reel them back in when
they're riffing way beyond the scripts
and that's again we can never use
children's movie but you know it was
great to watch those guys go and really
kind of learn from them and the
characters are different at the
beginning of this film and and so I
think that was interesting for them too
Mike we see such so much more of an
emotional side to Mike in this film so
Billy really had to you know really had
to bust out some emotional moments which
I thought he did beautifully and sort of
take Mike to a new place and John Salley
is more of a kind of a lovably arrogant
kid who thinks he understands how the
world works and and I you know I think
John really liked that actually he felt
like I I know kids like this I was a kid
like this we all were when we were 19 or
a lot of us were for sure that in the
first film
Sully's for the simulation of his fur
was incredibly difficult we did a couple
of years of R&D just to make that happen
in the first film fast forward you know
10 years while we're in production on
this film and we have that down pretty
well we've we've simulated a lot of
things since then clothing and and you
know the clothing I'm brave was was
remarkably simulated and and water and
Finding Nemo so we knew you know fur we
figured we'll be able to do that and so
the what we knew was going to be a
challenge on this film just as soon as
we had the idea of the story was just
the fact that we had to populate this
world
so many characters and so many different
types of characters and so we actually
spent a great deal of time and energy
working on that because that was
something that was just absolutely
necessary for the story and and but we
hadn't ever really done it to this
capacity yet at Pixar the number of
varied characters well we have a story
Department which are phenomenal and it
can be anywhere from well I guess it's
at its most its weight or people yeah
and along with myself and the writers
and we're we're we're constantly
developing the story not just in the
script form but the story artists are
you know essentially writers as well and
they're there pitching ideas all the
time and and not just gags I mean
they're pitching major story points o
matic ideas yeah and and that and
characters can kind of grow out of that
it's it's a it's a real collaborative
effort amongst that team but it really
is so important I think to be able to
tele you know tell each other kind of
when things are working and be honest
about it and when they're not and to
have that kind of relationship so it
this one worked out well it's kind of a
blind date that that turned into a good
marriage